Kaoru, a Happy New Year!
This is a souvenir from Hawaii.
Thank you.
You got sunburned.
I'm worried about the freckles.
You're too young to worry about freckles.
Oh, I have to.
My skin needs to be pretty by June.
Why?
My boyfriend proposed to me in Hawaii.
So, I'd like to inform you
that I'll resign by the end of the year.
You're resigning?
Yes.
I see.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I appreciate the support you've given me.
Hawaii sounds good.
It must be nice and warm over there.
By the way,
macadamia nuts seem to be
the default souvenir from Hawaii.
Couldn't she think of buying other things?
Come to think of it,
Mr. Kato and I were the only ones
getting macadamia nuts.
Mr. Kato, this is for you.
Oh, thank you.
Mika got a bottle of nail polish.
So pretty!
Kojima got a lipstick.
Oh, so that's what happened?
I find it strange. Don't you?
Besides, she's resigning due to marriage.
What is that? "Resigning due to marriage"?
Do people still do that nowadays?
Keep working, lady!
For the sake of the world,
of other people and the Earth.
There's a saying, "No work, no food."
Don't you agree?
Wait... No, I didn't mean that.
I can't believe Sayu is resigning.
I mean, her work is sloppy, but--
I-I have acne!
Wait, people don't call this acne
at my age.
I-It's a boil!